- Why do you say
what I think I'm doing?
It seems like people like you
would be saying
what I'm going to be.
- Because I don't want to count
my fucking chickens, Cha.
Honestly, I've done well.
I've made it.
I'm good.
I want to keep winning.
But, I don't know,
maybe I fall off.
- Mhmmm.
- Like I want to stay hungry.
I'm not ready to, you know,
DRock's like, "Hey, this cabbie
he knew who you were."
I'm like, "No, no, he just saw
"that you were
with a camera with me."
I have big enough
ego in me already,
I got to make sure that I have
big enough
humility to go with it.
- Mhmmm.
- 'Cause that's how
you get somewhere.
The second you think you've won,
somebody's gonna creep.
- Lost. Word up.
- That's so real.
A lot of these clichés and
stereotypes, they're real.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely.
- When you think,
we see it every day.
Did you see how,
I'm going a little old school,
but did anybody see
Buster Douglas walk into that
ring against Evander Holyfield.
- [Charlamagne] He got
his ass wiped.
- He thought he won.
Right, because he was fucking
40 pounds overweight.
- [Man] Yeah.
- He looked like he ate
the old Buster Douglas.
- [Charlamagne] (laughs)
Yeah, yeah.
- You know?
So, I'm scared of that.
And especially for as
much shit as I talk,
like I'm gonna buy the Jets--
- [Man] Yeah.
- I'm fucking suffocating myself,
put myself in a corner of
never being able to let off.
(upbeat music)